dans les rue de la régions.
Kim Vermette.
- Pour nous, il y a
vraiment un avant
et un après 1er juillet.
- Il habite le quartier
Longue-Pointe depuis 12 ans.
Jean-Sébastien Guénette
l'a choisi pour sa tranquilité.
Mais l'arrivée d'un refuge pour
personnes sans abri à deux pas
de chez lui a tout changé.
JEAN-SÉBASTIEN GUÉNETTE, rés. de
Mercier-Hochelaga-Maisonneuve
- Depuis quelques semaines,
on voit... on trouve
des seringues abandonnées
dans le quartier, on trouve
des sachets de drogue dure
dans nos cours, on voit
de la prostitution.
- 120 itinérants habitent
temporairement à l'Auberge
Royal Versailles. C'est que
le centre Pierre-Charbonneau,
où ils logaient,
a fermé ses portes et que
le refuge doit déménager.
- C'est pas l'idéal,
mais l'idéal, c'est
qu'il y ait pas d'itinérants.
- L'organisme CARE est en charge
du refuge. Le directeur général
savait que la cohabitation
serait complexe, mais trouver
la solution l'est encore plus.
MICHEL MONETTE, DG, Centre
d'aide et réinsertion Montréal
- Allez dans tous les grands
refuges, ils vivent tous...
ce genre de complexité-là
autour d'eux, de cohabitation.
On travaille avec les citoyens
pour leur expliquer.
- Mais les citoyens
ne se sentent pas entendus,
et ce, malgré des appels
répétés aux différentes
instances gouvernementales.
GEOFFROY ROLET, résident
- C'est clairement du tennis
de table administratif.
On est balancé à droite et
à gauche, sans réelle réponse.
- Le Service de police
de la Ville de Montréal
affirme porter une attention
particulière au métro Radisson,
en plus de patrouiller
régulièrement le secteur.
La Ville de Montréal est aussi
impliquée dans le dossier.
NATHALIE GOULET, resp. Comité
exécutif de la Ville de Montréal
- On est très compréhensifs
de la situation que vivent
les citoyens. Cependant,
écoutez, la décision d'ouvrir
une telle ressource dans l'Est,
c'est parce qu'il y avait de
grands besoins. L'intervention,
elle se passe maintenant,
et on espère qu'un équilibre
va pouvoir se trouver
très rapidement autour
de la ressource.
- Les recherches
se poursuivent activement
pour trouver un lieu permanent.
La Direction régionale de
la santé publique confirme
que le bail pour l'Auberge
Royal Versailles se termine
le 30 octobre. Mais une fois
passé cette date, les besoins
dans le quartier resteront
grands. On estime qu'environ
300 personnes sans abri
vivent dans Mercier-
Hochelaga-Maisonneuve.
Ici Kim Vermette,
Radio-Canada, M